Reggie said Julius has no chance and no
no business being in this competition
I'm just putting that out there yeah I
said it you get surprised us all but I
would never have a lefty win it oh God
his money rocked is the last Rock heat
up shoe
it was great last year Watching Carl
Anthony towns do okay
this is very respectful for the big
fella heat up dude
foreign
spot coming down in transition yeah
Trail three
he's on track for a career high in
scoring and rebounding this season for
the Knicks
this is big right here I needed that
again his money racket's the last rack
so he can make up time but he sits on
eight right now he's jumping to also
getting tired by the way every shot's
been short the last five until now he's
already set a career high this season
with the Knicks and three-point shots
made here we go also ran out of time
one second
[Music]
Rich you know you you would like to say
to me dreamer that's why I stay in my
wheelhouse brother
hey I applaud I'm even beat on this
stage trying it but these are
professional shooter these are guys
that's all they do
I don't know if you want to see this
that hurts yeah explain it to him now
it's okay hey I'm all strong that's the
All-Star Game
come on I came out of the Dugout
okay Kate don't think it's okay
it's okay it's funny